have you ever played a perfect game of
chess this Grandmaster just played a
game with 100% accuracy and four
brilliant moves Nicholas theodoro wasn't
afraid to allow his opponent the super
grandmas tamour rajabov to Fork his
Queen and Rook he had a plan a brilliant
Bishop sacrifice to draw out the King
after a check he took rajab's Bishop
even though rajabov was able to take the
rook and the point Advantage the game
was actually dead even a few moves later
Nicholas thought why not sacrifice the
other Bishop black King was in a
vulnerable position and after blundering
rookie 6 Nicholas was on the hunt one
final brilliancy was all it took to put
the icing on the cake there was no
stopping
checkmate